هذا هو لينز جرام
السيناتور الامريكي الذي هاجم السعوديه
تمرارا مره قال ان على امريكا شن هجوم حاد
عليها ومره حذر من تسونامي امريكي
ديمقراطي جمهور ضد الرياض
[موسيقى]
مواقف كثيره حملت نبره عدائيه
اليوم مختلف تماما
الناس الله
تغير لقاء جمعه بولي العهد السعودي الامير
محمد بن سلمان غرد بعده قائلا ان اللقاء
مثمر وصريح وان فرصه تعزيز العلاقات
الامريكيه السعوديه حقيقيه والاصلاحات
الجاريه في المملكه العربيه السعوديه
حقيقيه
لقد كان ليلي توي اجتماع مثمن للغايه
وصريح مع ولي العهد السعودي وفريق قيادته
العليا ان فرصه تعزيز العلاقات الامريكيه
السعوديه حقيقيه والاصلاحات الجاريه في
المملكه العربيه السعوديه حقيقيه بنفس
القدر موقف جراهام سبقهم تسريب لصحيفه
بوليتكو الامريكيه كشف انه وبعد مضي سته
اشهر من التصريحات الامريكيه بمراجعه
العلاقات الامريكيه مع السعوديه لم يحدث
شيء وان حديث بايدن عن عواقب ضد السعوديه
بعد قرارات خفض انتاج النفط كان سببه فقط
الشعور بالحرج
وليس بعيدا عن التغيرات في المواقف
الامريكيه الحاليه كان الرئيس الامريكي
السابق على موعد مع تصريحات اخرى هاجم
فيها اداره بايدن وشكك في قرارتها واثقه
السعوديه وقيادتها بالرائعه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات